the FBI says they're winding down their
investigation into Brett Kavanaugh
winding it down yeah yeah
Republicans are planning to keep this is
true keep the results of the FBI's
investigation of Brett Kavanaugh a
secret and store them in a locked vault
well he sounds innocent to me
[Applause]
did you see this at a packed rally in
Mississippi yesterday President Trump
mocked Brett Cavanaugh's accuser
Kristine Ford now as usual Trump warmed
the crowd up first by shoving a toddler
that's how he get some hot give me a kid
bang now where was I
let's come out that Donald Trump
personally had over a million dollars as
a seven-year-old yeah of course he lost
half of it when he got divorced as a
nine-year-old it didn't work out she got
too old you got to all
so nine that's his like god yeah oh she
was eight yeah Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
has officially become the world's
richest person beating out Bill Gates
yeah baseless was able to do this
because of Amazon's recent high ticket
purchases like twitch Whole Foods and
Bill Gates so how that works thank you
thank you very much thank you always my
favorite a laugh that turns into gentle
applause
[Laughter]
don't know what it means but I'll take
it I swear to God this jacket doesn't
fit I put this on just before I came out
and I'm like this jet this isn't my
jacket and I'm looking at myself in the
monitor I just said to Bruce Bromwich
backstage he just put this on me Bruce
where are you this jacket doesn't fit is
he back there look at this this is
insane hello he ran away did he
crazy he got this off a ventriloquist or
something the dummy is what I mean I
understand I know you men will get him I
look like a stand-up comic in the 80s
look at that
mr. roll their sleeves up
he's coming what's he doing right now
shrinking other jackets what's he what
is this
oh boy don't know it - what happened to
me I'm like the Hulk yeah yeah that's
the terrace hahaaa larious yeah alright
well I'll stick with this tonight back
to the jokes it's come out enough
laughing back to the jokes it's come out
thank you thank you thank you
you just made some writers feel real
shitty true story it's come out that
here in Los Angeles a home robbery gang
is targeting celebrities yeah police
have assured me I'm safe
I'm sure somebody will rob you home
really hope so I am yeah so Hollywood
leading man Christian Bale is playing
Dick Cheney in an upcoming movie yes
apparently the casting was done by Dick
Cheney hey thank you that's a company
has created robots that can pick fruits
and vegetables yeah
however the robots have already found
undocumented robots that oh good
[Applause]
you